Generally speaking, there are four important ingredients
to any information visualization. Visual cues, coordinate
systems, scale and data types, and context.
Let's use this line chart, which shows total
home runs by year in major league
baseball to showcase each of these ingredients.
So, the first ingredient was visual cues,
or visual encoding. This is encoding data with
shapes, colors, and sizes. For example, if we look at this
chart, we can show that each point shows the number of home
runs in a given year. And we can also see that
the lines connecting the points give us some sense of the rate
of change of number of home runs hit from year to
year. There were also coordinate systems. So we need to place our
data point somewhere on the chart. A coordinate system gives us
a structured space that dictates where the shapes and color should go.
This gives meaning to and x, y coordinate on
this chart. For example, in this particular graphic, the x-axis
represents time, and the y-axis represents total number of
home runs hit. Whereas the coordinate system tells us what
various dimensions of our visualization may correspond to, the
scale or data type will tell you where exactly your
data needs to go. There are three types of
scales that we could use: numeric, categorical and time series.
In this example, we're using numerical data on the
y axis, the total number of home runs, and
we have time on the x axis, the year.
Note that both of them are a linear scale, so
numbers are evenly spaced out. There are other type
of scales, which we'll discuss later. And the final important
ingredient of an information visualization is context. So, if
your audience is unfamiliar with the data, it's your job
to clarify what values in your graphic represent and explain
to people how they should read your chart. So, in
this particular visualization, I've provided some context by giving the
chart a title. Number of NLB home runs by year.
Labeling the axes, year and total home runs, and I
could do a little bit more by annotating the chart
potentially, so there are a variety of things that might
inform the total number of home runs hit in a
particular year, maybe the beginning of the live ball
era, which we might put somewhere over here. The
crackdown on steroid use, which happens somewhere around the
year 2000, et cetera. These annotations might help people
interpret this data and understand the story of, why
the number of home runs hit by year is
changing over time. It's important to emphasize that data
is the driving force behind all four of these ingredients.